house comb resumes welcome back to the
best the best playthrough gameplay
walkthrough lights flow of sims 4 on
YouTube you are a lucky man woman we're
back with Chen and anaconda Oh James
James is still here James
alpha James outside oh there he is
there's the details anyway what is
Hannah doing just what did she do hail
Sven 2.0 yes yeah actually let's have
one on each side that's awesome yes whoa
whoa calm down James calm down welcome
to gnome bill I still can't figure out
if this is a bug or if it's supposed to
be in the game but I love it I want one
of them to get a job
I'm sick of I want at least one of them
Anna anaconda should get a job and then
Chen can focus on getting [ __ ] cuz
he's old and stuff that's what they do
Nathan over this sound good look at the
gnomes it's amazing that's so close oh
my god okay a nightclub
[ __ ] it Oh Bella is totally going to
that's her name Bella got this - girl
from twilight sequencing gnomes they
know let's get drunk tonight ladies and
brows and nose she's happy now I don't
know she was capable of happiness if you
were that ugly where's the drink she's
going upstairs to make the drink how
does that I was justice oh why does it
look like she's giving her a weird back
massage
oh god it looks creepy look at her arms
what is that yay random push-ups
why not our house is like the [ __ ] now
with the gnomes it's the best house ever
let's be honest here
stop-attack she has him what is she
doing with him how dare you place it
there she's feeling really bad oh well
what are you gonna do there we go join a
career I found it all right click to
find a job for Ana join a career okay
okay
I want her to be a criminal oh my god
falcon lover is in this game I don't
know that that's awesome we need her in
your best oh god don't tickle each other
I don't know what you guys are doing but
I'm not asking any questions
James loved it
what what is she doing naked Bella goth
would like to come over and hang it
perfect I'm English
she's gonna work at Bella God is here
she's go to sleep now and there's a bed
right oh my god she's the dumbest
alright she has to go to work now I
think oh she actually go to work go Josh
we gonna get rich while we get a big I
ship them so much like I ship Shannon
Bella
like I ship fricking Simba and that
other Hawaiian girl ah she left
oh and China's still alone with that
booty there she is she's home how much
did you make us sixty three bucks is
that it you slob alright for those money
we will decorate on your bathroom oh my
god it's gonna have new wallpaper oh my
god we got the prettiest bathroom ever
why is she just standing there in her
panties what's the problem go jogging or
some [ __ ] go look at her face that's why
oh god she's gonna pass out [ __ ] what is
she oh god she's about to pass out oh oh
my god hello Chan wake her up talk about
cooking go and talk about cooking with
her it worked
well now he's still the bed there is a
chair here I mean it's bad why did all
my James go what the hell
where do they keep going oh nice man
boobs you have I didn't I didn't give
you credit for those Chen their
mysterious behind James I get someone in
the neighborhood is stealing my gnomes
oh look it's my favorite show I love I
love it
hello it seems to graphics there's in 3m
she got an achievement for being an
introvert you have a sim do nothing
social for 24 hours ha ha
not even in Sims not even in Sims go to
work nice outfit she goes to working by
the way just her panties I guess when
you're a criminal and that's one of the
whoa whoa whoa whoa Chad wake up Chan
she's old she's gonna dress stupid stuff
whoa what does she know what what are
you doing she really has a problem with
doors I don't know I don't know what it
is but she seems to like to stare at
them Oh guys she did she did it
Bravo Oh goddammit she left oh they're
doing push-ups why not
what else do you know in this world oh
my god chan I'm so disappointed in tan
like it's so hard to get a woman to like
him I guess it's just like real life huh
people keeps telling my dates what's he
doing trying to kill himself
don't do it John what is that alright
Bryce I'm sorry we're gonna have to end
the second episode here I hope you bros
enjoy watching if you did please go
ahead I don't even like it helps me out
a lot and it makes me do this thank you
very much for us and I'll see you
tomorrow as always stay awesome bro